Tung thẳng thì Israan bà Iran, vào dài đoạn, nguy hiểm khi ngay bệnh phần sau,
cun đo Israan Phát Cạnh bảo hình cấp, yêu cầu dân thường Iran sống gần các tư xử hả nhân và nhà mại của khí
phải xưa tạng ngày lập tức. Phát ngon viên được lượng phòng bệ Israan e ĐF, ông Abichay Adry,
Cạnh bảo vệ ở lại khu vực này sẽ đẻ giòa trực tiếp để tính mạc.
Đồng Thái trên trị ra trong bối cảnh Israan trên khá trị rơi quân xử xử từ chối dậy,
thực hiện hơn một chân nó mười của không tích trong bán ngày qua,
nhằm bảo các một tiêu trọc yêu trên lạnh thủ Iran bảo vệ của sở hả nhân khó tế lửa và chung tâm trị
vý quân xử. Bố trưởng của phòng Israan ông Israan Khác,
bình bố sẽ tiếp tục tần công để làm xí yếu nó lực quân xử của tây hera.
Một quan trực ăn những Israan cho biết,
việc sơ tàn dân thường là một phần trong kế hoa gây xửa,
đã được phay dùa tử trước về phần mình,
Iran cảo vụ Israan vượt lần dành đó khi nhằm bảo cơ sha nhân,
đồng thời tiên bố sẽ tự vẻ nếu tiếp tục bị tàn công.
Mói trưởng Iran, Arbats, Arachin,
Nhân Mark, các loàn đáp trả chỉ dừng lại khi Israan kế thuộc trên dịch quân xử,
xung đồ dừa hai nước đã gây ra tổn thất nặng nề trong bẩy miha dầu qua,
phía Israan sang nha tích nhất chính nước thình mạng và hai trong người bị thương,
gió tế lửa từ Iran trong khi đó Iran thùng bảo các cuộc không biết,
Ui Israan khiến bẩy miy tảm người chết,
hơn ba trăm hai người bị thương trong đó còn nhiều chiếc viên quân đội thức cao và chuyến ra hả nhân.
Dự lúc vì câu trên tranh khu vực cần kê,
được pháp và anh tương mũ sạch sạch đà phản ngày bị Iran về trực chính hạt nhân,
nhằm tìm kiểm lối thoát ngoại giao,
tương nhiên trên vọc lối thoại và thòn bỏ ngọt khi cả hai biêm tiếp tục tục tùng đòi quân xử,
lất lời cảnh bảo cửng gián.